c'est ici que tout a commencé les
premières victimes ont été contaminés
sur ce marché de la ville de vaughan en
chine 18 janvier 2020 un mystérieux
virus chinois fait son apparition dans
les rubriques du journal télévisé de
france 2
à bourg ain il a causé la mort de deux
personnes quarante cinq malades
présentent des symptômes alors comparé à
ceux d'une pneumonie ou d'une crypte
al'approche du nouvel an chinois et de
ses millions de déplacements
les autorités se veulent néanmoins
rassurante mondial avec les mesures
mises en place
nous allons empêcher l'épidémie de
s'étendre très vite les scientifiques
découvrent que ce nouveau virus
un corona virus est transmissible
d'homme à homme on le rapproche du
strass et avait causé la mort de 774
personnes entre 2002 et 2004 mais pas
vraiment de quoi inquiéter ce médecin
français le sras c'était la première
grande épidémie un peu prendre des mines
où il ya eu des cas partout là on prend
les choses beaucoup plus vite et on a
beaucoup appris et je pense que
l'ampleur va être beaucoup moins
important si même si c'est aussi grave
les autorités françaises disent prendre
la situation très au sérieux et traquer
le moindre cas suspects néanmoins
suivant les recommandations de l oms
les contrôles aux frontières ne sont pas
renforcés et agnès buzyn veut rester
optimiste
le risque d'introduction en france deux
cas liés à cet épisode est faible mais
il ne peut pas être exclue le 24 janvier
l'épidémie fait son apparition sur le
territoire
c'est ici dans le cabinet médical de sos
médecins à bordeaux que c'est présenté
jeudi le premier patient français
positif au cours d'un virus l'inquiétude
monte au sein de la population de plus
en plus nombreuses à vouloir se procurer
des masques alors que la communauté
scientifique ne sait toujours pas quel
est le degré de contagiosité du virus
qu'on sait pas si si des personnes sont
contagieuses avant d'être symptomatique
c'est un élément absolument clé pour
l'instant on reste au fait qu'on est
contagieux quand on a des symptômes mais
peut-être que ça évoluera alors que
depuis la chine nous parviennent des
images saisissantes de lujan comptines
et les nouvelles du premier cluster
français sont rassurantes ce après la
psycho c'est le soulagement en haute
savoie le coronavirus ne s'est pas
répandu dans la station de ski des
contamines-montjoie une accalmie avant
la tempête
le 11 février l'épidémie de kovy 19
franchi le cap des 1000 morts
essentiellement en chine si pékin se
montre confiant dans la maîtrise de
l'épidémie
l'institution de genève redoutent les
contaminations l international selon lé
coût de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé aujourd'hui la situation est
alarmante
c'est une grande menace pour le reste du
monde le 15 février
agnès buzyn annoncent le premier décès
en france d'un malade atteint du coc u19
évoque une éventuelle diffusion
pandémique du virus
fin janvier 2021 la france comptait 74
1106 mort du co vite 19
[Musique]